I wish I had better news for you about
the future of this country but we are
truly entering one of the darkest
periods for the United States of America
reports indicate that not Mitt Romney
not Rudy Giuliani not Newt Gingrich or
David Petraeus but the CEO of the oil
company Exxon will be the next Secretary
of State of the United States I'm
talking about rex tillerson a guy who
built his net worth of roughly two
hundred million dollars on the back of
destroying the planet through oil
drilling appears to be headed towards
being the top surrogate for Donald Trump
around the world continuing the
pro-russian connections Rex Tillerson
has ties to Russian President Vladimir
Putin which go back nearly 20 years this
is red alert level we don't like doing
Pat the alarmist conspiratorial talk but
this is absolute red alert level we have
a guy under tiller sins leadership
Russia became exons single biggest
exploration theater the company amassing
drilling rights across tens of millions
of acres in Russia but it goes way
further than that in 2011 on behalf of
ExxonMobil Tillerson signed an agreement
with Russia to drill in the Arctic that
could be valued at up to 300 billion
dollars the agreement was not carried
forward because of sanctions and acted
against Russia sanctions which as
Secretary of State Rex Tillerson could
work to undo and it doesn't stop there
Pat because in 2013 Tillerson was
awarded the order of friendship by
Vladimir Putin this is utterly insane
what is going on it is the kleptocracy
yep drain the swamp that's what we heard
this whole campaign cycle yeah I mean we
used to have politicians doing the
bidding of corporate interests and CEOs
now it just seems that we've eliminated
the middleman yet you you could just go
straight to the source Republican
Senator John McCain said on Fox News
that teller sins relationship with Putin
is a matter of concern Senator Bob
Menendez who's the top Democrat on the
Foreign Relations Committee said this is
an alarming and
third choice Exxon is going to make a
fortune when Rex Tillerson starts
lifting sanctions on Russia III know I
keep saying the word kleptocracy it's an
oligarchical kleptocracy there's really
no other way to describe it yeah i think
there's this idea surfacing that these
CEOs have made their money and now
they're just going to move forward and
and act in the best interest of the
country yet we've seen from the past
that's not true because for example Dick
Cheney's Halliburton stock increased
fivefold when ya came vice president if
it wasn't already clear that Russia and
Vladimir Putin would be playing Donald
Trump like a violin a guy who has a
two-decade history of doing business
with Russia who has been designated as
part of the order of friendship by
Vladimir Putin is going to be the
Secretary of State remind me how this
will make America great again for
anybody but Trump and his rich cronies
and I am not being conspiratorial but
this is just too much to make any
rational sense Russia hacked the RNC and
DNC as reported by the CIA and we have
now Donald Trump benefiting from that
hacking and looking for a secretary of
state he could have had Mitt Romney who
would have been at least the Statesman a
reasonable choice I don't agree with
Romney politically but it would have
been at least reasonable or David
Petraeus I would have thought it's too
much military in Trump's cabinet but at
least the guy has experience in
diplomacy but he's going to go with the
oil CEO with the two-decade history of
doing business with Russia I know some
people pats they'll think this is all a
big joke this III hope it is because if
it's not a joke this is horrifying yeah
I too was crossing my fingers for Mitt
Romney a secretary of state and if
that's what we've come to it's it's a
bad sign it's absolutely insane and I
know that people hear me say this and
they write to mean they say David you
lost just give it up make America great
again how is this going to make America
great again how is having the Exxon CEO
and the long list of deplorable that
Trump is hiring
in his cabinet and advisory roles how is
that going to make America great again
for the average American it is
absolutely not and that's what I want to
talk about next we've got Hanukkah
Christmas Kwanzaa and festivus all
coming up in the next couple of weeks
and whoever is on your gift list this
year you don't have to battle the crowds
to get a good gift for people you can
use shari's berries choose berries
dipped in white milk and dark chocolate
topped with everything from chocolate
chips to decorative swizzles our
producer Pat went crazy when he saw the
swizzle I could not imagine something as
simple as a swizzle could make him uh
just go completely nuts but it happened
and it's an incredible and unique gift
that is perfect for sharing even though
people you get it for may not actually
want to share and it's more than just
berries they have all sorts of seasonal
treats and gifts in time for the
holidays choose the delivery date and
shari's berries will deliver your gift
freshen on time guaranteed there is only
one way to get the 1999 shari's berries
deal and help to support the david
pakman show go to barry's dot-com that's
berr IES dot-com click on the microphone
in the top right hand corner and type in
my coat Pakman PA que ma n shari's
berries has something for everyone go to
Barry's dot-com click on the microphone
and type in Pakman to get the 1999 deal
today